there are four things that we can never
recover in our life we will do something
in the game of life you are playing a
cricket match against an entity called
the mind when you sweat a lot in times
of peace you be less in times of war
Juanes or get a mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's learn from one
of the basket we're Gopal das and some
of his best life-changing advice mentor
me go over okay let's take it off with
rule number one don't give in do
something in the game of life you're
playing a cricket match against an
entity called the mind no one on planet
earth can stop you from accomplishing
and achieving what you want if you can
bat
against the googlies that the mind pulls
at you how many of you have experienced
that the mild Bulls Pugliese
[Music]
good when it comes to exercising and
jogging how many of you know that the
mind bulls boobies much ahh
so job how many of you have trouble in
studying students and you come here you
hear all of these things don't get
distracted by whatsapp don't get
distracted by internet pornography don't
get distracted by Twitter don't get
distracted by Facebook study don't get
distracted by birds to do bird watching
study all this distraction is there
active days later gulosa do look up to
speed with Hilliker so on father was
telling his son take a Xterra class mail
Lucy and a Lucy
baby they first by you or to not like
hey loca Avila dig they came hey look
[Applause]
I'll tell you something my god why
because the mind doesn't want you to win
the game of life how many of you wanted
to wake up early in the morning
residents only one did I asked wanted to
wake up early in the morning and how
many of you have done something called
as setting an alarm clock and then after
setting the alarm clock that's an alarm
[Music]
you want it or not it rings and when it
rings the mind puts its first goobie
what does the mind do by putting the
googley makes you clean bold when you do
the first sluice
you are out
you are out if you snooze you are out I
want to say one thing just one and
probably this will change the direction
of your life you know something when you
snooze the Allah what happens you decide
to give in to the mind spa and this is
how your morning begins by giving into
the mind
sabira Quichua to PA his wall as a clean
bowled okay okay cam and shipping it
epidemic is Revati by giving him and
there's no problem giving in sleeping
five minutes extra is no problem the
problem is you develop the attitude of
giving in you tell yourself that what I
decided last night is not as important
what is important is what the mind says
because we listen I'll tell you
something my humble advice because it's
not just about getting up in the morning
it's about every aspect of life whether
it's your work if you're working whether
it's your study if you study whatever we
do
the problem is it's not about one thing
Saverio viana it reflects in every area
of life is limited oh avatar was in a
youth na maloom and hipness an iota
jarvis column lava lake in char pisco
route pour don't allow that snooze rule
number two utilize your time well there
are four things that we can never
recover in our life a stone after it has
been thrown into the valley words after
they have been spoken an opportunity
once it is missed and time once it has
gone considering the average lifespan of
a human being today to be about 70 years
17 multiplied by 12 is 840 now that's
how many months we have in our life
to live in this world and if life is
represented by a jar and those 840
months by the marbles in the jar every
year 12 marbles are being thrown out of
the child
last year 12 marbles have gone as well
gone forever
never to come back again look at how
many marbles you now have in the jar to
make a difference to leave a mark
to stand apart
utilize your time well and your time
will treat you well leading you into an
overall sense of well-being in the new
year to come
invest in taking care of your body
invest in nurturing and nourishing your
relationships invest in finding and
discovering your purpose your passion we
are calling in order to enhance your
professional growth invest in pursuing
and cultivating a meaningful deep
spiritually connect and for some reason
if you found yourself stuck in any of
these some of these or all of these
areas in the last year
the new year brings a fresh opportunity
to press the refresh button refresh the
page of your life and live well because
at the end of the day remember we are
all just stories
and make sure
is inspiring also if you want to have
more confidence check my 254 series
they're free the link to join are in the
description below no one on planet earth
can stop you from accomplishing and
achieving what you want it's easy to
make a buck very hard to make a
difference and whenever you're updating
to a higher version of yourself you have
to be able to give the best of yourself
to it rule number three live in the now
I think when we talk about being in the
present we don't have to start getting
into the present when the pressure is
high we need to start practicing being
in the present when the pressure is low
there's a very nice quote that I read
once in one of the barracks of the
Indian army which said when you sweat a
lot in times of peace you be less in
times of war
IPL for instance cricket now when the
match is on the world tournaments on the
the competition stuff is you right there
and under the spot which means the
pressure is high and you need to be
focused you need to be present you can
only do it effectively when you learn to
be present in the smaller things of life
I often tell people that when we talk
about being present one thing that we
should start practicing is start being
physically present like I give the
example I have a glass of juice here you
know when I'm sipping this mango juice
why do I need to watch television why do
I have to keep checking messages on my
phone what I'm doing by looking at the
television while looking at the phone is
being distracted from drinking the juice
so I'm drinking the juice let me just
drink the juice what's happening is I'm
being present physically present now
it's not so much about just being
drinking the juice but about cultivating
the attitude behind drinking the juice
of being present and what I'm doing I
also tell people beyond being physically
present we need to also be emotionally
present very often you see
people today are talking to each other
chatting with each other they're looking
around here and there the scrolling on
their phones they're looking at their
messages they're sending whatsapp
messages what they're doing is they're
completely getting distracted and not
learning to live in the now being
emotionally present means when I'm
talking to you for instance I am with
you I'm not looking at this plant behind
me I'm not looking at the camera here
I'm not looking at the cup of juice I am
looking at you I'm soaking in every
single word as you speak that's not just
about speaking it's about cultivating
the attitude of being present rule
number four get out of your comfort zone
they are all created to fly to live by
the incredible potential that we have
all been invested with but often we sit
on our branches clinging to the things
that are familiar to us remaining stuck
in our comfort zones not willing to
venture out not willing to take risks
the possibilities are endless but for
most of us they remain undiscovered
because we continue to conform to the
familiar to the comfortable to the
mundane so for the most part our lives
are mediocre instead of exciting
thrilling and fulfilling what is the
branch that's holding you back from
flying high what's the fear that's
stopping you from taking a risk
what is the weakness that's inhibiting
your growth unless we cut off the
branches we are clinging to and free
ourselves we can never take off and
reach new heights in our life what are
you waiting for cut the branch and take
your flight and you'll never find the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is break the mold then you're
wanting to do something out of the box
there's always going to be opposition
from a society where parents want you to
subscribe to a certain things a settled
job a settled life in terms of family
and your thinking completely out of the
box as soon as you want to do something
out of the box you're going to have to
face challenges from the family side
after a while however when my family saw
where I was reaching how I was impacting
people's lives however how I was really
able to make a difference in the world
they accepted it very well and I feel in
terms of coping up with the challenges
of how my friends have moved on the
industry I think it's a question of
self-discovery I hate I hate being a
part of a mold that the world created
for me I don't want to subscribe to the
mold that the world creates for you I
don't want to live a life in a paradigm
that the world is created for me I want
to discover my own mold I want to have a
paradigm that I have invented you know
only when you discover yourself only
when you live a life for what you are
created is when you feel happy satisfied
not just happy and satisfied you're
super effective even in the corporate
world today loads of people are just
living a life which they are not created
for because it pays the box and why do
they need the box to pay the taxes to
pay the pills bills to pay the market is
but they are not living a life of what
they are created for so it's basically
kind of you know fitting in just because
it pays you but I decided I don't want
to fit it so when I saw others moving on
my friends my colleagues moving on high
up I really did not feel insecure at all
because I didn't want to fit in to be
someone else I wanted to find myself
discover myself there's as soon as you
of successful in your self-discovery man
you are effective and completely
satisfied now I have a special bonus
clip from goer on how to be the best
version of yourself that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go question number
one what can you do to get out of your
comfort zone this week number two where
can you better utilize your time and
number three how can you live in the now
right after watching this video and if
you promise to take action after
watching his video we don't just watch
videos we do something about it
give me a hash tag believe down the
comments make that promise to yourself
and then get to work when I talk about
self-confidence I talk about trying to
be the best version of yourself you know
we are constantly updating our apps
we're constantly updating our operating
systems whether it's an iOS or an
Android and the updation of the apps or
the operating systems means to bring the
best versions of what exists and
whenever you're updating to a higher
version of your self you have to be able
to give the best of yourself to it if
you stick to the older version you reach
the plateau and you don't have to work
harder when you update yourself to a
higher version you have to give the best
of yourself in two hundred percent of
your energy there yeah hard work coming
out of the comfort zone which is where
many times I say you are your own
competition actually that's true
nobody is your competition that's true
we have to compete with ourselves every
single moment every single day to get
better than ourselves to get
the better versions of ourselves to get
the best version of ourselves so when I
talk about self-confidence I talk about
being the best version of yourself and
having that full confidence that I can
crack it I can get there
if you want to see the five
life-changing pieces of advice from
sadguru check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there that this is the most
sophisticated gadget on the planet not
the iPhone the eye but now the question
is have you read the user's manual